[Music]
crush and you are mr. Bhalla your stash
in your crown today I need one we want
to play a quick top five pageant
questions with you what do you consider
your best feature and why lick physical
I think my best feature
oh well I would say physical I can deny
ibly the eyes that my great grandma gave
me cuz I always say those piece of rent
what was your first memory after booking
mondo on Sesame Street oh wow um after
booking it remember actually I thought
of all the happy ones I remember calling
my mom who's that not a silly excitable
and I this happened and I have it and
I'm gonna do this and then she's like
did you sign a contract and I say oh not
yet but but it's gonna happen call me
back when you sign the contract she was
like she's right she keeps me grounded
best childhood memory growing up in
Puerto Rico listen one of the most
beautiful childhood memories I've always
had is um when I was like three years
old we lived in a house that didn't have
bathrooms so we had to shower outside
and we used a garden hose from my
neighbor and by that point I had no
cares in the world I didn't know that I
was like super poor I just knew that I
loved shower time and I always think
about that because it was like a tin and
I just it's in the mouth isn't beautiful
is what people pay to do now I thank you
laughing oh so authentic you know I was
like how didn't I loved in there and
then you know my my mom gave me the hose
for my on would be the thing I'm just
like showering naked in the mountains
like that oh my god I always remember
that I could not wait to like go and
shower like in that thing then I
realized that wasn't like the most I do
but it really is something that I
treasure and is really a memory that I
go back to because with all these
successes sometimes you take flight and
it's beautiful for me to connect with
that because I will always be that
person yeah and that's why I represent
happily and proudly